[Music]
mostly they're looking absolutely
stunning yeah so my mother's side of the
family is Jewish so bagels were always a
big thing in our house growing up and
they still are today but my mind was
truly blown when I went to New York and
ate the proper deli style bagels you get
over there they're huge and while the
bagels you get in the supermarket here
are fine they do a job they are nothing
like the real deal that you get in New
York can we try and recreate those do
you think I think it's worth a go such
an incredibly simple thing when you get
going
have you ever been to the bagel bakery
in Brick Lane yeah it's great yeah that
feels to me like the East End Jewish
tradition it's very different to the New
York thing and the New York thing is
very different to the California sort of
style bagel as well I think they have
them more fluffy and fresh of those that
you mentioned which which is your
favorite when you say are you are you a
New York bagel guide you know the West
Coast all those days I love them all of
their different ways I've had some
useful ones in New York I used to work
in an Ellie place in San Francisco and I
raised doors on a proper bagel platter
with all the bits and the fixings they
used to love that I think like every
other person who's been his teenage
years in London I used to spend a lot of
time with a brick laying bagel bakery
about 4:00 in the morning father three
friends of flour seven grams of salt
seven grams of dry yeast and then I'm
gonna put in a squirt of cheap Ronnie
honey any of you fancy manuka stuff is
any like this Oh God look don't put
anything fancy in your purely using it
as a sweetener it's only middle-class
guilt was [ __ ] me chucking in a
handful of white sugar 320 grams of
water are you gonna use a dough hook or
you're gonna be manly under my hand
getting get my fingers in that's the way
that's the way you taught me it's the
way I've been doing it ever since
poor sap I'm putting it over a toe book
you do it until it feels smooth and then
we're going to rest it between one and
three hours wait to the doubles in size
first of all flour your table top and
turn out your dough lift it out probably
start looking a bit like a focaccia
spreading out like a bit of a pancake
don't do it by pushing down in the
middle do it by lifting up the side
divide the dough in half quarters
stretch each quarter out a little bit to
make it easier to cut it in half again
just being gentle shape into balls one
thing I wanted to ask you about was was
bagel toppings because when I went to
New York I tried it the first time why
they call in everything bagel which as
the name suggests has pretty much
everything in here I think it's onions
sesame seeds poppy seeds might even be
something else
I dunno heavy onion world is when they
put raw onion into it I suppose you
could but should finely chopped raw
onion over the top there's two ways of
shaping a bagel one of them is to take
your dough to roll it into a sausage and
then wrap it around into a circle and
stick it to itself okay so the other way
to shape them up is to take a ball
Jeremie a thumb through the middle and
then pull it outwards I think I like
this method actually it's a bit neater
isn't it it might leave a pretty absurd
did you mom do a lot of like proper
Jewish cooking when you were growing up
yeah I mean a lot of which of course I
couldn't eat chicken soup in and
whatnots oh that's just some kind of
level of deprivation to have a proper
Jewish mom who actually cooked for you
and you choose to not get a suit oh man
you are so going to help the Jewish
penicillin I know I turned veggie really
really young as well I was like six or
something my mum pulled no punches of
sausage you know what happens to the
piglets they're so cute so well what the
hell tomorrow and they're slaughtered
and we need them in our bacon sandwiches
and that was it I was done with me let's
hope you respect that although still I
blame you for the chicken soup thing
that's insane yeah I just know how
delicious it is yeah you know what I
grew up eating lacus yeah which are just
an amazing thing it's a really good
vegetarian option if we make these well
enough maybe we can say once your mum
see what she thinks she's gonna be
watching this video carefully I think ah
no pressure there yeah as if you get any
pressure from a Jewish moment if they're
a bit rough and ready and rustic looking
that's fine isn't it hey you've only got
to please your mother my bagels it's
safe to say are looking exactly uniform
but they have risen quite nicely I've
got the water lightly morning yeah to be
really
squirts of honey into the water and this
is what gives it the sweetness it also
helps to cause the caramelization on the
surface it gives you that lovely sort of
brown wrong finish on the for the baby
Baker in the end teaspoonful of bicarb
and what is the bicarb in the water
they're gonna do so that helps the
outside to form a sort of tougher chewy
a coat which you don't want in bread
that you really do want in a bagel and
we'll do about 30 seconds on one side
then flip them over and about 30 seconds
on the other side when they're done back
onto the floured baking tray or into the
topping on one side must so they're
looking absolutely stunning yeah they've
got a real springy rubbery consistency
to them to try and recreate the
everything bagel before it goes on the
up and just create a bit of onion on it
to see what happens oh my eyes we're
gonna cook these for 20 minutes right
then I think I might have slightly
overdone it with the poppy seeds on my
puppies this is the one I'm most excited
about wonder whether it's worth this is
my everything everything bagel onions
cooked mean sweet perfect okay that's
that's what we hoped so you just grated
that on the surface did you yeah just on
the top along with the toppings yeah
I'll try that next time because the
other thing about grating onion is you
create a lot of onion juice yeah this is
why you were tearing off and that will
also flavor the top big smear of cream
cheese on each one the inside looks good
it's an amazing texture it's much softer
than the ones I'm used to it they look
fantastic
and when you got half the pot of cream
cheese and I should probably save some
for the kids but I'm not sure I want to
serve it with slice of lemon some capers
I've got some some gherkins here Israeli
style pickles for me it's the lemon
juice and pepper you done I just go open
our orange instead of the lemon I've
ever heard of anybody being fruit
dyslexic
oh the textures fantastic to me that's
much more New York than East End oh it's
really nice mmm it's got that chewiness
there you want from the bagel and the
onion on the top has really worked quite
well I'll try that next time you know
lockdown is nearing its ends and I think
like a lot of people I went into it and
decided to cook a bit more and try out a
few different things the one thing I'm
going to take away from it is
baking I've got the boat for it and
thank you for that I don't really sort
of teach cooking that much
Kent's been great and some of these
things have been things I haven't cooked
for ages have been lovely to do them
again and sometimes the results are
ramshackled but it's just been such -
laughs yeah doing it and you're minding
yourself you can't find thank you thank
you
mmm that's really good
[Laughter]